[Musique]
tellement
étrangère
[Musique]
étrangère [
Musique] [Musique
] [
Musique]
soixante-dix pour cent des ménages ruraux
sont
engagés dans l'agriculture en Inde, ce qui
vous indique qu'il y a une énorme
population
qui dépend de l'agriculture  dont les
moyens de subsistance dépendent de l'agriculture,
donc je pense que progressivement, les agriculteurs se
rendent compte qu'ils ont été soumis à des
chaînes courtes, ils ont été emmenés faire un tour
pendant toutes ces années,
ils ont été laissés face aux aléas
des marchés et je pense que c'est
l'argument que je vois  des agriculteurs,
c'est qu'ils veulent un
revenu assuré, cela n'a rien de particulier
à l'Inde, si vous regardez l'Amérique, regardez l'
Europe, les agriculteurs, ils
veulent aussi un revenu assuré,
faites-le
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
étranger
vous